so we have uh continued protests
and growing unrest in different parts of
the country
and i'm really going to focus in today
on the political implications
particularly when we have
just you know about eight weeks left
until a presidential election that
hinges significantly
on the idea of do we need
another four years like the last four or
do we need
something different that's the context
that we should be applying
to the upcoming election and so in
portland oregon
we saw a pro-trump mob drive
through the city one person was shot
dead
we've seen clashes involving mace spray
and paintball guns we saw trucks firing
projectiles
into crowds and driving into people
here's a video of pickup trucks with
trump flags
and american flags a pepper spraying
people
and driving into individuals
a union building was set on fire
here's video of trump people shooting
paintballs and pepper spray
at other individuals who were protesting
and just absolute
complete and total chaos ensuing and
there's a couple different layers of
this that we should really discuss
the first is what are the realities and
the facts about the protests themselves
and then the political impact which i
think is far more relevant and
and actually it's something we can
discuss in much more tangible terms
even though the the political impact is
more
speculative than the facts on the ground
i would argue it's actually a much
simpler and more straightforward
conversation to have so
the first thing is in terms of the the
realities like what is happening in
different cities
cities are being uh uh filled up with
trump people and protesters
who are protesting uh police brutality
uh black lives matter protesters etc
donald trump is insisting he needs to be
re-elected to stop
the chaos in cities that doesn't pass
the sniff test
and we're going to talk about that but
before we do that
i i think it makes sense for us to
maybe get on the same page about
what are the conversations that we
should be having online on social media
and which conversation should we
probably skip
and a lot of the debates are over what
portion of the unrest is coming from the
left
and what portion of the unrest is coming
from the right
and i'll tell you it's completely
fraught to go down
that road and what i mean by that is the
following
if the violence that we're seeing not
protesting protesting is
for you know protected by the first
amendment and the protesting
is not the problem although some people
will tell you it is if the violence
was 95 trump people
and 5 black lives matter or
if the violence was 95 black lives
matter
and 5 trump people it really doesn't
make a difference in terms of the
political impact
and it's a debate that you will never
be able to get agreement on and people
are going to be focusing
only on that the unfortunate reality is
that more chaos and more violence helps
donald trump and i know that there are
some people on the left who disagree
with me on this
there are some people on the left who
are insisting wait a second
people will see violence under donald
trump
and they will blame trump at least
partially for the violence it's
counterintuitive
trump is president now and there's chaos
now how does violence and unrest help
donald trump
the narrative has been lost and remember
half the country doesn't vote and so a
lot of this is who do you
get to go and vote okay now
in that context chaos in the streets
favors the person supported by the
military gun types
regardless of whether it makes any sense
i hate that this is the reality i really
do
trump seems to realize it and later in
the program i'll talk to you about how
kellyanne conway
is admitting it and the more chaos
there is either way
it's beneficial to donald trump unless
we really turn the vote out now again
i'm getting
when i've been tweeting about this
including over the weekend people write
to me and they say david you're wrong
people see violence under trump's watch
and it hurts him i do not believe that
that is correct
the chaos activates trump's base
this idea of dangerous democrat cities
has been effective for activating donald
trump's
base and again the election
will be influenced by people who change
their minds
but it's mostly check out my interview
with rachel bittikoffer it's mostly
going to be a reflection
of who is activated and who chooses to
go out and vote
the framing from trump of course
is that it's mostly violence by black
lives
matter against white people
trump supporters whatever the
unfortunate reality is that that's the
wrong area to be focusing the debate
because
imagine that we get out there
successfully the narrative that it's not
mostly violence from black lives matter
it's mostly violence
from trumpists well then they'll just
say well yeah the trumpists have
have to be out there because there's
chaos in the streets
you saw it with kyle rittenhouse now
there's the debate oh well kyle
rittenhouse
he was actually he didn't bring the gun
across state lines somebody gave him the
gun in wisconsin
oh well kyle written house was filmed
two weeks ago sucker-punching a girl so
it when you start making the debate
about that
you get lost in the weeds and the
unfortunate reality is that trump
benefits on this no matter what i hate
to say it
because it activates certain people it
pushes certain buttons for lack of a
better term
if it's chaotic people might be less
likely to want to change horses
midstream
if trump stops the violence he will take
credit and get it from some of the
people who would be predisposed
to be open to that type of idea if trump
sends in the troops
it activates his base it's a real sort
of
rorschach test or an ink blot of
possibilities
and the next thing i want to talk about
is kellyanne conway straight up
admitting this
and also talking more about the dynamics
of why this is beneficial to donald
trump
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense
each one into text or audio that you can
get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video